MOS plays soccer whenever he can break
away from the board he's got a mean
backand and he's Moonlighting as a model
me live there's never been much money in
chess but Magnus is changing that
sponsors are lining up to endorse him
he's making about a million5 dollars a
year but it's a solitary life Magnus is
on the road 200 days a year now between
matches he is alone in his hotel hotel
room getting ready for tomorrow's game
he works out almost every day knows he
can't concentrate for it's often 7 hours
unless he's in shape Magnus says he
wouldn't be able to tolerate this life
if it weren't for his father who's
always there for him when you travel
with Magnus what's your
role I'm a servant and a chess fan